[Musique]
le chat a dit écrire sans faute pour
écrire sans fautes
certains ont déjà du mal à ce stade une
cruelle n'est ce pas alors je ne sais
pas vous mais moi j'aime beaucoup ce
personnage du chat imaginée par le
dessinateur belge philippe geluck qui
vient nous bousculer nous sortir de
notre torpeur nous faire voir le monde
différemment et surtout nous faire voir
différemment en ce que l'habitude nous
fait oublier
et il se trouve qu'une fois encore le ch
a fait mouche
si je puis dire avec talent parce que ce
qu'ont constaté dernièrement dans les
médias que ce soit la télévision dans
les journaux et la radio c'est que
l'orthographe est devenu un véritable
enjeu économique pour les entreprises
l'orthographe leur coûte cher leur fait
perdre des contrats et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'on constate
également c'est que nous tous que ce
soit à titre professionnel ou à titre
personnel eh bien nous sommes toutes et
tous amenés à écrire tous les jours à
produire du contenu que ce soit des
mails des des comptes rendus des textos
ou bien également tous les jours sur les
nombreux réseaux sociaux des postes dont
j'aimerais aujourd'hui répondre à deux
questions
première question pourquoi faisons nous
tous des fautes d'orthographes et
deuxième question est bien au fond
pourquoi l'orthographe est elle
importante
en ce qui me concerne j'ai toujours eu
cette curiosité gourmande pour les mots
des plus communs aux plus rares et pour
des formules qui sonnait à mes oreilles
de façon magique comme dans le petit
chaperon rouge tire la chevillette et la
bobinette cherra que je ne comprenais
pas tout à fait également d'autres
formules du genre la mariée ira mal
camp français on peut lire de gauche à
droite mais également de droite à gauche
vous pourrez essayer après à un accent
prêts et nous verrons que sa taxe en
fait toute la différence
également en verbe que j'aime beaucoup
c'est le verbe rêver qu'on peut lire
aussi de droite à gauche et de gauche à
droite et aujourd'hui et depuis plus de
18 ans et bien c'est dans l'édition que
s'exerce ma passion pour la langue est
également comme formatrice et avec mon
équipe de correcteurs nous avons
accompagné de nombreux auteurs à la
recherche du mot juste de l'expression
juste et l'exercice croyez moi est loin
d'être aisée en restant toujours au
service d'un style est au service d'une
voix alors bien sûr cela voulait dire
aussi corriger l'orthographe et la
typographie et d'ailleurs c'est à cette
occasion que j'ai appris que dans
l'expression un arbre sans feuilles et
bien il faut un sa feuille parce que si
l'armée n'avait et des feuilles
justement il y en aurait plusieurs c'est
également là que j'ai appris que
après-midi peut être accordée au
masculin ou au féminin alors bien sûr au
sein d'un même texte au sein d'un même
roman il faut choisir mais les deux sont
possibles et étant originaire du sud
ouest de la france
eh bien j'ai une nette préférence pour
le féminin une après midi ensoleillé et
eux c'est là aussi que j'ai appris qu'à
une certaine époque il existait une
différence ténu mais bien présente
entre faire de nouveau c'est à dire
faire plusieurs fois et faire à nouveau
c'est à dire effacés et refaire à neuf
alors je vous rassure aujourd'hui rares
sont les personnes qui connaissent sa
différence de sens tant il est vrai
qu'en matière d'orthographe et de
langues est bien celle usages qui
prévaut et l' usage vos qu'aujourd'hui
vous puissiez employés l'une ou l'autre
des deux expressions indifféremment à
nous
vaud est de nouveau alors je m'arrête là
parce que je pourrai continuer pendant
des heures mais vous l'aurez compris la
correction réclame une concentration
extrême ainsi qu'une posture de doute
quasi permanente est véritablement
épuisante
faut-il heureux faut-il rs foothill de
zèle il me souvient dans les premières
années à la fin de la journée
j'avais le cerveau qui bouillonnait et
gens venaient à douter de tout presque à
chercher maman dans le dictionnaire aime
pas marg3 que c'est bon allez je passe
donc aujourd'hui laissez moi être votre
guide dans cette balade au pays de la
langue française est restée avec moi
jusqu'au bout je vous donnerai une
astuce simple et directement applicables
qui vous permettra d'améliorer vos
écrits
question numéro une pourquoi faisons
nous tous des fautes d'orthographe
alors vous ne pas pas ici du défaut de
connaissance que nous pouvons avoir tous
et toutes de certaines règles du
français le français est une langue
réputé difficile
à juste titre et pour ma part je ne
filme tous les jours sa connaissance
cependant les principales règles les
principaux écueils sont en nombre limité
et peuvent être révisées en quelques
heures d'études dont je ne parle pas de
cet aspect là qui est bien sûr
essentielle mais qui n'offre pourtant
pas une complète garantie contre les
coquilles faire ce que dans le jargon
d'édition on nomme les coquilles vous
savez ce sont ces petites fautes qui
crissent sous la dent qui crise qui
accroche l'oeil est vraiment un petit
sondage lever la main s'il vous plaît
ceux qui parmi vous se sont déjà
retrouvés dans la situation suivante
imaginez vous êtes devant votre
ordinateur vous rédigez un message
[Musique]
vous leur lisez vous appuyez sur la
touche envoi pour immédiatement vous
rendre compte que vous y avez laissé une
erreur qu'elle soit de contenu ou
d'orthographe lever la main s'il vous
plaît je lève la main parce que je me
suis déjà retrouvé dans cette situation
et cela m'arrive malheureusement encore
aujourd'hui
bon je vois beaucoup d'entre vous merci
pour votre épée alors en tant
qu'amoureux des mots eh bien lorsque
j'ai une question je me tourne vers mes
fidèles compagnons mes amis de toujours
c'est à dire les dictionnaires et pour
répondre à cette question pourquoi
faisons nous tous des fautes
d'orthographe
eh bien je me suis emparé de mon grand
robert de la langue française est gelée
posé avec fracas sur mon pupitre jeudi
ouvert il est véritablement très gros et
puis je les feuilletés feuilleter fêter
jusqu'à tomber sur la définition du
verbe lui dire et c'est là que robert
nous apprend que le verbe lire provient
du verbe latin les guérés qu'elle donc
donné en français plus tard le verbe
lire mais également au gré des caprices
de l'évolution de la langue
le verbe et lire lire élire
si bien qu'on peut dire que lire c'est
d'abord et avant tout choisir il cette
notion de choix qui est inhérente à
l'acte de lire
elle m'a particulièrement intéressé par
ce que l illustre parfaitement la façon
dont vous et moi
lisons le français de manière naturelle
c'est ce que montre la recherche en
psychologie cognitive de la lecture nous
ne lisons pas tout les syllabes d'euros
et nous ne lisons pas tous les maux dans
une phrase
à propos des mots eh bien nous les
reconnaissons dans leur ensemble
à propos des phrases notre oeil parcours
le texte à la recherche de ceux qui sont
les plus importants les plus importants
pour la lecture c'est à dire les plus
porteurs de sens les noms et adjectifs
et les vers blancs tête
ensuite notre oeil et notre cerveau
reconstitue la phrase d'après la
connaissance intime que nous avons de
notre langue c'est ainsi qu'on peut dire
que la lecture est une succession de
fixation et de saccades
je répète la lecture est ainsi une
succession de fixation et de saccades
est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'entre
deux fixations l'oeil est aveugle
je ne sais pas si c'est une bonne
nouvelle quoi qu'il en soit la
conséquence pour celui qui se propose de
relire un texte quel qu'il soit c'est
que les erreurs risque fort de lui
échapper
parce que son oeil et son cerveau les
auront automatiquement gommer et
automatiquement corrigée par ailleurs
celui qui relie lui même des phrases
dont il est à l'origine voit se dresser
devant lui un deuxième écueil
d'abord nous l'avons vu l'écueil de ses
habitudes de lecture ensuite l'écueil
tendu par son statut d'auteur qui fait
qu'il va encore moins dans ce cas relire
ce qui est écrit mais bien relire ce
qu'il sait ou plutôt ce qu'il croit être
écrit alors je ne sais pas si c'est
également une bonne nouvelle
quoi qu'il en soit j'en arrive à ma
question numéro 2
au fond pourquoi l'orthographe est elle
importante et cette question quand on la
pose et la nommer immédiatement une
troisième qui est la suivante quel
objectif premier poursuivant nous
lorsque nous adressons un écrit quel
qu'il soit investi la terre quel est
notre objectif premier est bien
l'objectif premier est de toucher
l'autre par la pertinence d'une idée par
le contenu d'un message
nous cherchons à transmettre une
information
nous cherchons à plaire nous cherchons à
convaincre
or la faute d'orthographe
brou une autre message en polluent le
contenu mais surtout la faute
d'orthographe distrait le destinataire
du contenu premier du message alors j'ai
pour vous trois exemples où la langue
nos pièges si je vous dis j'ai acheté
l'appartement de ma voisine que j'ai
tant convoité voyez où je veux en venir
comment écrivez-vous convoité convoité
est convoité et e
les avis divergent
alors bien sûr les deux sens possible
tout dépend du sens et tout dépend de
qui parle
est ce un investisseur immobilier qui
convoitent l'appartement où est son
amoureux qui convoite la voisine tout
dépend du sens alors vous aurez reconnu
la règle de l'accord du participe passé
avec le complément d'objet direct
lorsqu'il est situé avant le verbe
un deuxième exemple maintenant si je
vous dis et si on mangeait virgule les
enfants
qui parle dans ce cas là c'est un parent
qui appelle ses enfants pour le repas
alors d'après mon expérience il peut
toujours attendre maintenant enlever la
virgule
et si on mangeait les enfants dans ce
cas là ce n'est plus la même chose
n'est-ce pas c'est l'ogre qui parle à
l'ogresse à propos du petit poucet et de
ses frères comme quoi parfois la vie
tient une virgule
j'ai pour vous un troisième et dernier
exemple il ya quelques temps un célèbre
avocat de l'appellerons monsieur v
reprenez sur une scène de théâtre
les moments marquants de sa carrière
l'affiché était libellée en ces termes
étaient visibles dans le métro
monsieur v à la barre hélas hélas et je
vous laisse savourer la coquille dans
les premières impressions de la fiche
l'accent sur le à avait été oublié alors
bien sûr les internautes se sont emparés
de la sphère twitter en tête où ils se
sont demandés avec une certaine malice
et une certaine mauvaise foi si le
spectacle était interdit aux moins de 18
ans dans les impressions suivant de la
fiche l'accent sur l'eau a été rétablie
mais cet exemple vous montre bien qu'en
français et bien l'accent à une pleine
valeur orthographique et c'est bien la
principale réponse à la question
pourquoi
l'orthographe est elle importante
l'orthographe en tant que code commun
partagé par tous les utilisateurs du
français et refait des usages parce
qu'au fond l'orthographe et surtout sa 1
re fait des usages porte notre sérieux
et notre crédibilité
elle est en somme la politesse
de celui qui écrit et encore une fois je
me suis tourné vers les racines des mots
tant il est vrai que l'examen des
racines démo permet d'enrichir le sens
actuel et d'enrichir également
l'imaginaire que nous y associons il m'a
toujours absolument fasciné que les mots
texte et textiles proviennent d'un même
mot latin qui est ex tous il est vrai
qu'en texte se tisse patiemment fil à
fil et couleurs après couleurs et que le
dessin final d e2 et sienne ou dessin
final de2 s e n 2 s'apprécie vraiment
qu'une fois la lecture ou l' ouvrage
achevé il ya la manière d'une étoffe
bien ajustés sur le corps qui sait se
faire oublier pour mieux mettre en
valeur celui ou celle qui la porte
un texte bien corrigé transmet votre
message avec justesse pour me toucher
celui ou celle qui le reçoit texte et
textiles maintenant fut chose promise
chose due dès lors pour améliorer vos
écrits l'astuce est simple mais
redoutable donnez vous un objectif de
lecture donnez vous un objectif de
lecture notre cerveau humain est
champion pour trouver ce qu'ils
cherchent
ou plutôt ce que vous lui demander
explicitement de chercher alors re lisez
en conscience pour vérifier le style
vérifier les informations vérifiées les
répétitions ou relisez en conscience
pour traquer les coquilles vérifier la
graphie des mots et toutes autres
questions de forme et d'orthographe
vous allez grandement gagné en
efficacité alors bien sûr cela suppose
de s'astreindre à plusieurs passages
successifs
au moins un pour le font au moins un
pour la forme et dans l'idéal en
laissant reposer quelques heures le
texte de façon à pouvoir y porter plus
tard un regard distancié pour conclure
les photographes brouille votre message
et en polluent le contenu au contraire
une bonne orthographe porto vos idées
vos histoires et vos émotions
alors je vous invite lorsque vous vous
relisez à vous donner un objectif de
lecture focalisez-vous sur le fond ou
focalisez-vous sur la forme
vous communiquerez ainsi avec davantage
de force d'impact et d'élégance merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]